قتلى وجرحى في انفجار هزه شارع الاستقلال
في تقسيم ما باسطنبول وفاه ملهم فيلم
تورنال ايراني عاش بالمطار 18 عاما مفاجات
بحادثه اتوبيس الدقهليه السائق يتعاطى
المخدرات هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقولها لكم
من قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم
انفجار ضخم في منطقه تقسيم بمدينه اسطنبول
هزه تركيا ونشر الهلع فيها فيما لا تزال
حتى الان الخلفيه والاسباب غامضه اسطنبول
تسبب الانفجار في مقتل عده اشخاص واصابه
اكثر من العشرات بينهم حالات خطيره واظهرت
صور لحظات الاولى للانفجار الذي وقع في
الشارع في ما سادت حاله من الفوضى بين من
كانوا في المنطقه وقد هرعته الامن والدفاع
المدني وسيارات اسعاف الى المنطقه في حين
اشار الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان الى
ان الانفجار سببه قنبله موقوتا واصفا
العمليه بالارهابيه والدنيا
توفي الايرانيه مهران كريم ناصري في مطار
تشارلز جول الذي عاش فيه من عام 88 حتى
عام 2006 بسبب مازق قانوني متعلق باوراق
الاقامه الرجل الايراني الذي الهم توم
هانكس عام 2004 في فيلم ذا تورنال عاش
بالمطار محاطا بعرضات تحتوي على ممتلكاته
المتراكمه وامضي ايامه يكتب عن حياته رغم
ان الناصري حصل في نهايه المطاف على حق
العيش في فرنسا لكن الامر انتهى به
بالعوده الى المطار قبل اسابيع قليله حيث
توفى اصابته بنوبه قلبيه
على خطى شركتي تويتر ومتى تستعد ديزني
اكبر شركات وسائل الترفيه في العالم لموجه
تسريحه بعد ان اعلنت عن خفضا في عدد من
الوظائف عقبه تسجيلها ارباحا وارادات اقل
من التوقعات خلال سنه 20 22 ماليه يعمل في
ديزني نحو 190,000 موظف اسهم الشركه
تراجعت بشكل حاد لتصل الى ادنى مستوى لها
في 52 اسبوعا قبل ان تنتعش في وقت لاحق
كما خسرت ديزني نحو الملياري دولار في
الربع الاخير من هذه السنه وهو اكثر من
ضعف خسارات العام السابق
في مصر قرارات نيابه العامه حادثه سائق
الحافله التي سقطت في قناه مائيه بمحافظه
الدقهليه شمال القاهره في حادثه اسفلت عن
مصرع 24 شخصا واصابه اخرين وذلك لتسببه في
هذه الماسات الانسانيه تحقيقات النيابه
المصريه بينت ان السائق المتهم بالتسبب في
الحادث يتعاطى المخدرات اذا اكد التحليل
المبدئي للمتهم تعطيه مخدرا وكشف بيان
للنيابه عن تفاصيل اضافيه نقلا عن شهادات
المصابين بان سائق الحافله كان يتحدث فيها
هاتفه المحمول حين فوجئ بسياره لم يستطع
تفاديها لسرعه سيره ما تسبب في وقوع
الحادث
وفي خبرنا الاخير زفه الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب ابنته وتفنى لرجل
اعمال ينحدر من عائله اللبنانيه ثريه في
حفل حضره الجميع بولايه فلوريدا العريس
كان تقدم لخطبه تفني اثناء وجود ترامب في
البيت الابيض قبل نحوي عامين واهداها
حينها خاتما للزفاف قيمته مليون ومئه الف
دولار فيما اعلنت عائله ترامب زواج تفاني
قبل ايام من اعلان والدها ترامب موقفه حول
ترشحه للانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 20 24